he's a senior reporter of mm QB from
Sports Illustrated we appreciate him
taking his ear from the ground long
enough to represent this Honda inside a
report here on the Rich Eisen show he's
Albert Priya how are you Bert
I'm good I'm good great great to see
that your team showing some heart there
right yeah yeah you're talking about
fantasy which which team you talk about
sounds like they've got some so they've
got some real heart you know what Albert
it's what beats inside it really is what
beats inside okay here we go this is a
big day Albert a big day rumors are
getting crazier and crazier and crazier
what's the craziest name you've heard
that's available today for the right
price yeah you know I think some of the
to me it's like sort of some of the guys
who have been a little disgruntled and
have history and and and quietly I think
some of these teams you know we're sort
of you know looking at the idea of
moving badnesses you know sort of the
same category that Jalen Ramsey was in
looking to move them because you know is
it's just the ideas they get a return
for these guys and sort of what if this
light clean at certain positions is
intriguing and so you know what would be
Le'Veon Bell
you know the Jets running back who
signed with the team you know seven
months ago and you know I I think really
is would be available for the right
price and then various play the
cornerback from the Lions I'm told that
they've made him available another price
it could be high but you might remember
so I was pretty pretty pretty critical
of the team's trade of quandary Diggs
last week and you know Matt patrician
has done a really nice job setting the
culture in that building it wasn't
perfect last year but you know I think
that they really feel like they're sort
of making their way out of the woods now
on that and you know if they can get a
big return for Darius so I think there
was a feeling that could be another step
in that direction what about Cameron
what about Cam Newton who has been just
sitting there in rehab but we'll have to
take a flight to the west coast what's
going on there
Carolina where Kyle Allen the day after
getting having his first beatdown as a
professional quarterback has named the
starter for week nine what's going on
there Albert well I tell you this the
Panthers are committed to letting him
get 100% well and I'm not just talking
about physically well I'm talking about
mentally well they want him to be in the
right head space to play again and you
know part of it for cam I think is
always been how his body feels and you
know while he was cleared in September
to play the first two games of the year
there wasn't feeling there that mentally
you know dealing with the different
injuries that he's dealt with it started
to get to him so you know III know this
they've you know committed Allen for now
and as far as I've been told it's what
never cam is 100% ready to go and again
that's mentally physically everything
whenever he's 100% ready to go then
they'll have the discussion of what
they're gonna do but for right now Kyle
Allen's the quarterback they're waiting
you know for pro cam to get where he
needs to play again and when he gets to
where's just to be to play again then
they'll move forward I can't imagine
that you would hear his name involved in
any trade talks today not that anybody
wouldn't call but I just I don't think
the Panthers are there yet at that point
with them what about our buddy glaze
thrown out there what uh you know I'm
here in as a room or two and I'm sure
you might be is there any smoke or a
fire with DeAndre Hopkins and the Texans
Albert what is up with that
yeah I was told yes I was told yesterday
not like first of all I want to say like
you know Jay is exactly you know I would
never I you know I I think you know
wherever he says you can take to the
bank
detectives have gotten phone calls on on
DeAndre Hopkins it which is what Jay
reported I've been told that they said
they are moat they are they they have no
plan to book him today that said the
idea of it on paper could make some
sense and the reason why you know Bill
O'Brien's wanted you know all along to
build the team through the lines of
scrimmage and they were able to really I
think this is kind of been one of the
untold stories the first half of
season the Texans have basically fixed
their offensive line issue they spent
the first two picks and April's draft an
offensive lineman Titus Howard max
scharping and then they traded a
boatload of picks to go and get Laremy
Tunsil which allowed them to vote power
to the right side sharping inside the
guard they feel like they've done what
the Colts did last year and fixing their
offensive line
the thing is they gave up a ton of draft
capital to get it and so you know if you
think creatively how when we go without
recouping some of that capital you look
on your roster you see who would be
worse that sort of return and Hopkins is
one of the few people's people on that
roster that would slow to that kind of
return so that's why other teams have
sort of raised their eyebrows and said
okay well is there somebody on the Texas
roster that may be quietly available and
so you know that's I think a huge part
of why the huge why Houston's got those
phone calls again my understanding is
they're not looking to trade them right
now you know but certainly I think it's
one of those names that teams just kind
of quietly keep an eye on and you know
or at the very least thinking to
themselves I wonder if he might some at
some point come available so they can
make up for everything they lost they
make up for everything they lost no I
know that but when you get the Tunsil
trade to fix your offensive line it's to
give Watson enough time to find Hopkins
that's the whole idea isn't it I mean
unless Albert there's something going on
behind the scenes because you know teams
as you know teams hear stuff and they
sense the if you read blood in the water
and it's not like they're I don't know
how teams are putting two and two
together about boy the Texas really need
to replenish their draft choices who
would be the guy to do it let me make
the call
they must know that there's something
about favor in out or something right
sure and I would say this like I did
this was probably July or August you
know and I can't remember something had
happened with the Texans and I got a
text from somebody who's with another
team who said to me watch Hopkins is
next and I was stunned by it you know I
was fourth I was like why would they
trade the best receiver in the league or
I mean whether or not is the best one of
the two or three
receivers in football right and I was
like I was like why and just you know I
guys guy who I was texting with his nose
with another team and was three or four
reasons why and said here's why he would
do it
and and and to some degree it made some
sense and so I like what you're saying I
think exists like there is a feeling out
there that at some point he could become
available which is why he's one of these
guys teams are gonna keep trying on and
you know what to I mean like that's how
they wound up getting Tunsil I mean if
you think like the Dolphins did not have
an intention to trade Laramie consular
there were two players in August at the
ten that the Dolphins basically said you
didn't call on these guys but work for
book we're not contending to trade them
and those two guys were Larry tonsils
avian Howard and the Texans just kind of
kept coming you know and it's like well
what about this well what about this
well what about this and it eventually
got done and so maybe if somebody's
really really determined and keeps
upping the ante that way the way to
Texas did not tussle maybe something
eventually happens I just don't see it
happening today
Albert brear from the mm QB in the Honda
insider report here on the Rich Eisen
show what about AJ Green Albert it's
just been you know understand look
people take some time to heal it's just
been odd to say the least they need to
win and he's rehabbing and now suddenly
they made it to the trade deadline and
and they're on a bye what do you what do
you have for me here on that front yeah
like I can just tell you that the teams
that have gone to the Bengals asking
about their veteran players and it's not
just AJ it's other guys like Geno Atkins
that you would think all right like this
guy's in the 30s like maybe they would
maybe they would look at doing something
have gotten flat no and the one player
that I I I can tell you like his at
least elicited come back and forth from
Cincinnati to Tyler Eifert because
they've got a young tight end behind it
they really like and drew sample but you
know they they very much been of the
mind not to move any of their veteran
players and really I think there are two
things behind that number one even when
the Bengals have been really bad like
Mike Brown has never has never conducted
a fire sale so it's not it's not in
their nature to do it
number two I do think that there's a
feeling that they want to give Zack
Taylor who's just 35 years old who had
never been a coordinator even before
this year they do want to give Zack
Taylor a chance to build a foundation
for 2020 over the back half of this year
and if you're offloading all the
planners worth anything on the roster
it's gonna be much harder for him to do
that and so I think for those two
reasons the Bengals are likely to hold
on to everybody except for maybe Tyler
Eifert and I think even Tyler Eifert you
need to send a pretty decent wrap it
going back nattie to get Albert Brewer
here on the Rich Eisen show you
mentioned Darius Leigh potentially being
on the market because of his public
criticism of the way that the team is
handling the roster we saw Joe Flacco
call out the coaching staff for their
lack of their there their lack of
aggression on trying to win a football
game in Indianapolis that they lost and
then the next day he's got a neck
problem that's causing him to miss some
time and he certainly didn't look like
he was in traction when he was calling
out the coaching staff is there what's
up with this one is there any there
there I'm not I've been told I've been
told you know he's going to he's going
to get a second opinion in the next
thing as real that said I'm not blaming
you for arching eyebrows on this one you
know it was very it was very it was very
interesting what he said very publicly
after the game on Sunday that's a new
coaching staff that's trying to
establish on the way that they do
business and I think it's pretty clear
that you know now the reality of where
they're at
has sort of sunk in and you know that
was reflected in the Emanuel Sanders
trade it could be reflected later today
if they move Chris Harris and so you
know I I think it's certainly fair to
ask the question you know maybe
something was nagging Joe Flacco and you
know now is the time curiously enough to
get it taken care of I can't tell you
definitively whether or not you know
what he said about you know Vic Fangio
and Rick's King gorilla and the
decision-making I can't tell you if any
of its related to his medical condition
but I certainly understand this
bishop so tell me why Elway wouldn't
pick up the phone call Carolina and say
what do you think if cams available I'll
flip you one
why wouldn't me why wouldn't you do
something like that what do you think
because I don't think it seems close now
was the whole intention with Joe right
when you trade for Flacco like you don't
make a move for Joe Flacco if you don't
think that you're in a position to
compete and you know that's always been
a always nature is you know not to give
up on seasons and again like you know
the move to get Emanuel Sanders out of
there ahead of the end of his contract
the fact of Corsairs I think would be
available for a second-round pick today
if anybody wants to bite on that he's in
the contract here too I think is sort of
I attempt to me it just shows you that
there's a realization of where they're
at right now they like they're they like
the to draft classes that they've had
the last two years but they're coming
out of a major slump in that department
and so I think the idea is going to
build around the 18 and 19 draft classes
if you're going to get Kim Newton that's
very much it went now strike while the
iron's hot type of move and I just I
mean look they're not in the same
position to say oh the Chicago Bears
will be able to do something like that
you think the Bears would what's going
on there with true Biscay who the team
and Maggie had to say hey he's starting
cuz you're already here in the the shark
circling and every single time that
Watson takes a throw and mahomes makes
it throw it just makes it worse yeah and
that's a hard thing to I mean like look
like Maggie was there in Kansas City
when they tracted mahal know what I mean
like so he was he was actually part of
looking at the quarterbacks in that
draft class and you know so he was on
the other side of this too
I mean look I think they're saying what
they have to say I mean right now
they're I'm for better or worse
arrey to them you know they traded out
form they took what the second overall
pick and I don't know there's anything
that they can do to make the earth move
before the before the trade deadline at
4:00 p.m. and the thing that's so
difficult about this rich and you know
this is you know great quarterbacks give
you you know a huge window of
opportunity right they can create
stability in a franchise for 10 to 15
years a great defense can create that
sort of window of opportunity but it's
much much shorter usually if
a great defense in this day and age the
window last what two three four or five
years something like that and then
you've got a retool again and so that's
what's so hard about the physician that
there's are in and I think it's going to
be part of the position that they're in
going into next year when they're gonna
have some cap issues to work through
where it's where we built this great
defense but how much longer will you be
able to keep it together how much longer
the guys and their prime going to be at
this level and you know I think
ultimately that that's going to be a
very real question for them at least
after the year where they have to ask
themselves so we need to do something at
the most important position to try to
get what's left get get out of what's
left of this of the defense that we put
together ask the poll question of Albert
brear to wrap up the Honda inside a
report Chris born out of last night and
whether the dolphins are in line for the
first overall pick and as you pointed
out many teams are already looking over
the the steering wheel of next year's
draft what do you have over there Chris
yeah what kind of head to 2020 who would
you take first overall next year to a
jobber o chase young well I guess I have
to chase young right if I was a dolphins
if I was a dolphin
yes I would like honestly guys like if I
were the Dolphins I would look at this
for a two-year window okay
and I would be evaluating to uh I'd be
evaluating Justin Herbert who you didn't
mention who I think is gonna be in that
mix I'd be evaluating Jill borough big
from Washington somebody who I think you
know with a strong second half the year
could declare I'd be evaluating those
guys but I'd also be evaluating guys
like Trevor Lawrence and Justin fields
and so you know I I would tell you right
now I probably take two uh because the
guys at Alabama compare him to Drew
Brees and I mean the big concern with
him would be durability and whether or
not he's gonna be able to hold up
long-term in the NFL but he's got some
special skills I'd probably say to her
right now but the idea of taking a chase
younger this year and then looking next
year looking at the 2021 quarterback
class I think there's some merit to that
what if the Bengals wind up with it
which is entirely possible Albert what
if the Bengals do what do they do yeah I
think the Bengals I think the Bengals
would be open to drafting a quarterback
next year right although although the
ability to
young in stairs they kick tires in the
quarterback this year I know I know but
the the the opportunity to maybe keep
chase young in state and see if Zach
Taylor does love Dalton I don't know I
mean right I mean I would say this to
like the having Andy Dalton I think
gives you the flexibility to wait you
know like I mean look like Andy isn't
playing as well as he was four or five
years ago but if you build
infrastructure around them you'll get
you on a Williams back next year at left
tackle he could be fine like you can
tread water with Andy Dalton just fine
and get yourself to the next year's
draft class if that's what you want to
do and you're not wild about to Herbert
or Burrell or whoever else you know and
so I was actually married to the idea
like hey we've got Andy Dalton his
numbers his financial numbers look very
very reasonable right now let's just
ride it out with him and if we got to
make a decision and 2021 to take a
quarterback we can do that right now
let's go and get the best player the
best player is chase young well and then
in terms of that just in the last minute
I've left I have no compunction other
than just to say thank you for calling
in and giving you the floor here on Nick
Bose as a defensive player of the earth
we're currently sitting here right now
correct fact yeah no I I mean it's I
tell you this it's the same guy that and
I was told people assorted rabbits the
same guy we saw the first three game to
the last year before you got hurt and I
talked to Richard Sherman about him you
know on Sunday after the game and
Sherman said to me like I knew in August
what we had and I asked him well how to
know just our training camp is like Joe
Staley couldn't block him and he was
like he's like when you've got an
all-pro like a multiple time all-pro out
their left tackle and he's having fits
trying to block the guy it's like it's
like you know you know what you've got
and so you know I I think that what
we've seen from Nick Bose is very very
real he's in the perfect scheme and that
Seattle type of scheme that allows the
defensive linemen to wreak havoc and
right now based on how the Niners are
playing defense I think you have to look
at him as a potential
Defensive Player of the Year candidate
and I think for that matter you also got
to look over at New England and how
they're playing defense because those
two teams are playing up like a two
in Ravens 85 Bears type of level you
know I think you got to look at a guy
like Jamie Collins from New England too
so there are some good candidates but I
think big poses certainly in the mix
which is pretty interesting for a guy
who is a rookie
Albert really appreciate the time I have
a I'm sure you're gonna have a very busy
rest of the day we'll chat in short
order thanks for the call brother
awesome awesome thanks appreciate it
right back at you at Albert Breer I got
to read him in the mmq be for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app